With six films released in the Conjuring franchise
so far and at least three more planned for
the near future, how do all of these films
stack up?
Are all possessions created equally, or are
some spirits more pernicious than others?
While the first Conjuring film is often warmly
regarded by horror fans, Annabelle, the prequel
that followed in 2014, is not.
Annabelle made a respectable $257 million
worldwide, but reactions to the film were
far from kind.
This spin-off focuses on a couple welcoming
their first child while also being terrorized
by a possessed doll that seems intent on taking
the mother's soul.
What sets Annabelle apart from other entries
in the Conjuring Universe is just how stale
and uneventful the overall film feels.
Throughout most of the film, the haunted doll
hardly moves or really even bothers the couple
who owns her.
Outside of some shots of Annabelle looking
intimidating or being positioned ominously
in a room, there isn't really much to keep
audiences on the edge of their seats.
"What do you want from me?
WHAT DO YOU WANT FROM ME?!"
The Curse of La Llorona follows a mother trying
to protect her children from the titular undead
spirit.
The film wastes what could have been an interesting
look at an underrepresented piece of Hispanic
folklore by instead making it into a formulaic
ghost movie.
The characters don't really have any interesting
personalities - particularly the children,
who function more as props to drive the plot
than as actual human beings.
Motherhood and conventional ideas about protecting
children are highlighted extensively, but
there's ultimately no commentary about those
themes.
In the end, the film says nothing meaningful
and only manages to deliver a few cheap jump-scares
before the spirit is defeated and the film
ends.
With its gothic set design and period costumes,
The Nun might be the most visually interesting
entry in the franchise.
However, a nicely constructed set and some
interesting costumes aren't enough to make
a film function, and it's safe to say viewers
weren't impressed overall.
The film follows a novitiate who is determined
to find the root of the evil now emanating
from the monastery and banish a spirit that
has taken the form of an undead nun.
The Nun is packed with a handful of boring,
one-note characters, plenty of lazy dialogue,
and a deluge of forgettable jump scares.
Ultimately, The Nun manages to feel completely
flat and devoid of creative substance, despite
having some stylistic flare.
Annabelle Comes Home serves as another prequel
to the the first Conjuring film.
After Ed and Lorraine Warren come into possession
of the cursed Annabelle doll, the couple safely
confines the possessed plaything away from
the world.
Of course, one slip up is all it takes for
Annabelle to cause havoc.
When a girl wanders into the Warrens' locked
artifact room and accidentally releases Annabelle,
chaos reigns.
Now free to terrorize as she pleases, Annabelle
releases a slew of angry spirits from the
couple's collection of cursed objects, turning
the once peaceful Warren home into a demonic
house of horrors.
While Annabelle Comes Home isn't the worst
film in the Conjuring universe, it is definitely
one of the most boring.
With a few exceptions, the demons aren't noteworthy
enough to make them stand out from the more
interesting cast of unholy spirits we've seen
in previous films.
The Conjuring 2 is one of the best received
entries in the Conjuring series, but it still
feels a little like the creative team tried
and failed to recapture lightning in a bottle
with this sequel.
Like the first movie, The Conjuring 2 follows
Ed and Lorraine Warren as they work to save
a family from the demon that's tormenting
them.
The film feels like it was made with the intention
of setting up an expanded universe instead
of telling a complete, self-contained story.
Aside from the crowded roster of spirits,
the primary demon gives its name to Lorraine
in the beginning of the movie, which is the
key to defeating it in the end, making the
resolution feel rushed and unearned.
"I do know your name.
I asked you.”
“TELL ME WHO YOU ARE!”
“And you told me!”
Despite these gripes, The Conjuring 2 is still
a worthy successor to the first film, making
use of interesting camera work, a slow build-up,
and the creepy imagery that fans of the franchise
have come to expect.
Featuring a cast of likable characters, lots
of creepy build-up, and tense pacing, Annabelle:
Creation reaffirms that the Conjuring series
can still deliver the paranormal frights that
horror fans crave.
As a prequel to the first Annabelle film,
Annabelle: Creation shows the origin of the
demonic Annabelle doll.
The film features competent acting from the
cast of child actors and decent writing to
support them as well.
Though some of the scares end up falling flat,
there are some genuinely visceral moments
that help drive home the sadistic nature of
the demon.
There is a unique balance in Annabelle: Creation
between highlighting the emotional punishment
endured by the possessed and the physical
punishment doled out by the sadistic spirit,
letting the two complement each other and
build in anxiety-inducing ways.
The first entry in the franchise is also the
best.
Because there was no pre-existing, familiar
film universe for audiences, The Conjuring
had to be particularly paced.
Instead of being thrown into the paranormal
with little explanation, the characters are
forced to do research, set up and monitor
equipment, and work with local police just
to get enough proof to have an exorcism approved.
As a result of all the added legwork, not
only does The Conjuring feel more believable
and accessible for audiences, but the frightening
pay-offs feel earned.
The chief marker of this film's quality is
the building of atmosphere.
This is demonstrated particularly well through
how reserved and understated some of the scares
are in the film.
The musical score is allowed to be soft and
to serve as a background to scares, instead
of the blaring, bass-heavy blasts that punctuate
jump cues in later movies.
Additionally, the minimal CGI used throughout
the film is also done with precision, demonstrating
that less really is more.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.